comencemos poniendo atención a las
siguientes imágenes logras reconocer las
que son observarlas un poco más las
imágenes que viste se llaman fractales y
son figuras que se forman cuando las
repetimos varias veces por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una línea luego se hicieron
otras cuatro después de esas cuatro se
agregaron otras cuatro en cada línea y
así hasta que se formó el arbolito en la
siguiente imagen la figura central es un
camión y al igual que en el caso
anterior sólo se fueron agregando más
camiones hasta que se formó una figura
nueva pero que tienen en común exacto
ambas figuras se construyeron a partir
de un patrón como recordarás en
matemáticas le llamamos así a las reglas
que nos ayudan a ordenar los términos de
una sucesión el día de hoy veremos cómo
encontrar algunos patrones que te
servirán para crear tus propias
sucesiones ahora
mira la siguiente imagen se encuentra en
la figura que más se repite
bien hecho la figura que más se repite
es el triángulo en el techo de la casa
vamos a descubrir el patrón numérico que
hace que las figuras se vayan acomodando
en cierto orden empecemos lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es analizar cómo se
construye nuestra figura para hacer
nuestro triángulo necesitamos tres
líneas vamos a dibujarlo una dos y tres
hagamos el triángulo que sigue como ya
tenemos uno de los lados sólo
necesitamos dos líneas más vamos con el
que sigue ok
otras dos líneas empecemos con el
tercero qué bien otras dos líneas el
cuarto dos más
creo que ya descubrimos algo verdad
sigamos quinto triángulo otras dos
líneas perfecto encontramos la regla que
hace que el techo de la casita se vaya
formando y es el 2 al irse agregando dos
líneas cada vez se han formado uno
siete ocho y nueve triángulos en el
techo de nuestra casita
ahora vamos a representarlo en una
tablita este es un pequeño tip que te
puede ayudar cuando tengas que construir
figuras o descubrir patrones en la parte
de arriba escribimos el número de
triángulos que tienen nuestro techo 12
7 8 y 9
en la parte de abajo colocamos el número
de líneas que se ocuparon para hacer los
triángulos empezamos con 3
15 17 y 19 bien puedes observar que para
cada triángulo el número de líneas va
aumentando de dos en dos vamos a
representarlo con números
matemáticamente quedaría de la siguiente
manera
el número de figura lo multiplicamos por
2 que es el número de líneas que se van
incorporando para formar un triángulo
finalmente le sumamos 1 que es el número
de triángulos que se forman cada vez que
aumentamos las líneas entonces la
representación numérica de la sucesión
sería la siguiente 3
15 17 y 19 genial hoy aprendimos algunos
tips que nos pueden ayudar a encontrar
los patrones de una sucesión ahora
podrás crear tus propios diseños te
invito a practicar qué diseños podrías
armar con las siguientes figuras